if I was running Facebook for a day
you know the big opportunity in my
opinion was really not the metaverse
but it was actually getting the closest
that anybody could get to AGI
and if I had to steal man that product
case here's what how I would have
pitched it to the board into Zuck I
would have said listen
there are three and a half billion
people monthly using this thing if we
think about human intelligence very
reductively
we would say that there is a large
portion of it which is cognitive
and then there's a large portion of it
which is emotional
we have the best ability to build a
multimodal model
that basically takes all of these
massive inputs together to try to Intuit
how a system would react to all kinds of
stimuli
that to me would been a profound Leap
Forward for Humanity can you dig into
that a little bit more so in terms of
uh now this is a board meeting how would
that make Facebook money
I think that you have all of these
systems over time that that we don't
know could benefit from
um some layer of reasoning to make it
better
um
what does Spotify look like when instead
of just a very simple recommendation
engine it actually understands sort of
your emotional context and your mood and
can move you to a body of music that you
would like what does it look like if you
know your television instead of having
to go and channel surf you know 50 000
shows on a horrible UI you know instead
just has a sense of what you're into and
shows it to you
um what does it mean when you get in
your car and it actually drives you to a
place because you should actually eat
there even though you don't know it
these are all random things that make no
sense a priority
but it starts to make the person or the
provider of that service
the critical reasoning layer for all
these everyday products that today would
look very flat without that reasoning
and I think you license that and you
make a lot of money so in many ways
instead of becoming more of the pixels
that you see you've become more of the
bare metal that actually creates that
experience and if you and if you look at
the companies
that are multi-decade Legacy kinds of
businesses
the thing that they have done is quietly
and surreptitiously move down the stack
you never move up the stack to survive
you need to move down the stack so if
you take that OSI reference stack right
these layers how you build an app from
the physical layer to the transport
layer all the way up to the app layer
you can map from the 1980s all the big
companies that have been created right
all the way from Fairchild semiconductor
Nat semi to Intel to Cisco to three com
you know Oracle Netscape at one point
all the way up to the Googles and
Facebooks of the world
but if you look at where all the Locking
happened
it's by companies like apple who used to
make software saying I'm going to get
one close I'm going to make the bare
metal and I'm going to become the
platform or Google same thing I'm going
to create this dominant platform and I'm
going to create a substrate that
organizes all this information that's
just omnipresent and everywhere
so the key is if you are lucky enough to
be one of these apps
that are in front of people
you better start digging quickly and
moving your way down and get out of the
way and disappear but by disappearing
you will become much much bigger
and it's impossible to usurp you yeah I
100 agree with you
um that's why you're so smart this is uh
the depersonalization and
the algorithms that enable deep
personalization almost like a operating
system layer so pushing away from the
interface and the actual system that
does the personalization I think the
challenge is there there's obviously
technical challenges
but there's also societal challenges
that
it's like in a relationship if you have
an intimate algorithmic connection with
individual humans you can do both good
and bad and so there's risks that you're
taking you can so if you're making a lot
of money now is Twitter and Facebook
with ads surface layer ads
what is the incentive to take the risk
of guiding people more
because you can hurt people you can piss
off people you can
um I mean there's a cost to forming a
more intimate relationship with the
users
in the short term I think you said a
really really key thing which is
um which was a really great
emotional instinctive reaction which is
when I said the AGI thing you said well
how would you ever make money from that
that is the key the presumption is that
this thing would not be an important
thing at the beginning and I think what
that allows you to do if you were
Twitter or Google or Apple or Facebook
anybody Microsoft embarking on building
something like this is that you can
actually have it off the critical path
and you can experiment with this for
years if that's what it takes to find a
version one that is special enough where
it's worth showcasing
and so in many ways you get the free
option you're going to be spending any
of these companies will be spending tens
of billions of dollars in Opex and capex
every year and all kinds of stuff
it is not a thing that money
um actually makes more likely to succeed
in fact
you actually don't need to give these
kinds of things a lot of money at all
because starting in 2023 or right now
you know you have the two most important
tectonic shifts that have ever happened
in our lifetime in technology they're
not talked about but these things allow
AGI I think to emerge over the next 10
or 15 years where it wasn't possible for
the first thing is that the marginal
cost of energy is zero
not going to pay for anything anymore
right and we can double click into why
that why that is and the second is the
marginal cost of compute is zero and so
when you when you take the
multiplication or you know if you want
to get really fancy mathematically the
convolution of these two things together
it's going to change everything so think
about
what a billion dollars gets today when
we can use open AI as an example
a billion dollars gets open AI a handful
of functional models and a pretty fast
iterative loop
right
but imagine what
um openai had to overcome
they had to overcome a compute challenge
they had to strip together a whole bunch
of gpus that to build all kinds of
scaffolding software they had to find
data center support that consumes all
kinds of money so that billion dollars
didn't go that far so it's a testament
to how clever
that openai team is but in four years
from now when energy costs zero and
basically gpus like you know they're
falling off a truck and and you can use
them for effectively for free
now all of a sudden a billion dollars
gives you some amount of teraflops of
compute that is probably
the total number of teraflops available
today in the world like that's how
gargantuan this move is when you take
these two variables to zero